[Musique]
enfin
les sujets de recherche de notre invité
nous sommes probablement
99% à ne rien y comprendre les mots
qu'ils utilisent ou qu'il a utilisée
dans sa vie de physiciens l'on connaît
même pas l'existence
si je vous dis séparation isotopique ou
accélérateur à cavités supraconductrice
pour électrons ça ne vous dit rien à moi
non plus mais lui il sait et sa force
c'est de partager ses connaissances d'y
ajouter même une dose de philosophie
pourquoi cherche t il à ce point nous
donner un peu de sa science perty
patience parfois devant moins
connaisseurs que lui on va lui poser
toutes ces questions bienvenue dans un
monde un regard bienvenue etienne klein
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
nous sommes donc dans le dôme tournon au
sénat c'est vrai vous auriez pu garder
tout ce que vous savez pour vous
pourquoi avoir eu envie de partager avec
les autres est ce que rendre l'autre -
ignorant ça protège du chaos non ce
qu'il ya des très belles cités en
physique au 20e ses études et révolution
conceptuelle incroyable une qui
s'appelle la relativité générale
proposée par la style en 1915 qui change
complètement la façon de comprendre la
gravitation et après il ya eu de la
physique quantique qui décrit les
interactions entre particules et là il
ya des idées qui ont été mis sur pied
dans les années 1920 par des jeunes gens
très rapidement qu'on fait une véritable
révolution en inventant des concepts qui
sont pas les concepts qu'on utilise dans
la vie de tous les jours c'est quand
même des idées qui méritent d'être
connues y compris par ceux qui n'ont pas
eu la chance de faire des études mais ce
qu'on est les effets soient mis dans ce
cas la cité intellectuelle pour les
comprendre ces choses doivent comprendre
qu'on peut essayer il n'ya pas d'à
priori qu'on puisse mettre en avant et
j'ai pas du tout une conception scolaire
de la démocratie moi je pense que mon
départ moins bons citoyens si on est
indifférent à la science on a le droit
de ne pas du tout si intéressé mais
c'est bien d'être mis en contact avec
elle au moins une fois pour voir si on a
du coup pour elle est ce qu'il y ait des
choses impossibles à vulgariser est ce
que là par exemple il ya un sujet sur
lequel vous ne prendriez même pas la
peine de m'expliquer les choses
tellement c'est complexe je pense que
tout est vieux gars is able à condition
qu'on ait beaucoup de temps et on a
rarement du temps et par exemple la
physique elle s'écrit pour ce qui les
forme à l'image des équations
mathématiques et dire avec des mots ce
que dirait une équation c'est le pouvait
parler ça prendrait beaucoup de temps
donc il faut en plus on n'est jamais
bien sûr de ce qu'elle dirait au quai
tout un travail de traduction mais je ne
crois pas que la langue ordinaire la
langue avec laquelle on parle tous les
jours qu'on tienne la science est donc
pour vulgariser il faut creuser une
langue étrangère dans la langue pour
créer des espaces nouveaux dans lesquels
on va pouvoir dire l'originalité des
messages qui nous viennent de la
physique c'est une langue à part des
dons c'est plutôt une critique du
langage
faire de la vulgarisation ces critiques
et le langage c'est être en lutte avec
la langue comme disait un de mes maîtres
bildstein et pourquoi c'est impératif de
la partager cette scion c'est que au
moins une fois on soit en contact avec
elle dans sa vie mais parce que c'est du
temps c'est excitant en temps de parler
de s'y intéresser de tenter de la
comprendre il ya
il ya un érotisme des problèmes voilà
par exemple
il se pose une question et tente d'y
répondre la réponse amène une autre
question il suit le fil et c'est la mène
au bout d'un temps qui peut être plus ou
moins long à des véritables
bouleversements révolution c'est quand
même excitant enfin la pensée c'est pas
forcément triste et une joie de la
pensée après on fait ce qu'on veut
encore une fois ce n'est pas une
obligation mais c'est bien d'essayer
elle aime le ski
avec le co vide tout le monde se prend
un peu pour un scientifique c'est un peu
ce qu'on a remarqué
croit comprendre les choses invente même
des théories farfelues qui finalement
n'ont plus rien de scientifique est ce
que ça vous effraie en tant que
scientifique d'avoir observé cela disons
que je suis passé d'une conception grâce
aux qu'ovide d'une construction
intellectuelle de la vulgarisation je
pense qu'il fallait transmettre des
idées à une conception plus politique et
c'est le coville qui m'a montré parce
qu'en effet au début moi je pensais
qu'on avait là l'occasion historique de
faire de la pédagogie scientifique
d'expliquer jour après jour comment on
travaille quelles sont les questions qu
est qu'on se pose quelles sont les
expériences les mesures les protocoles
qu'on met sur pied pour répondre aux
questions que nous posons
expliquer ce qu'est un essai en double
aveugle ils sont des traitements un
essai randomisé
pourquoi il ne faut pas confondre
coïncidence corrélation et causalité
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une exponentielle
pourquoi la théorie des probabilités
parce qu'on utilise beaucoup de
probabilité dans ce genre d'affaires
elle est parfois contre intuitive et au
lieu de ça on a dans beaucoup d'endroits
organiser les controverses prématurés
entre jean pas d'accord à propos de
questions dont on ne connaissait pas
encore les réponses comment ça on
organisait qu'il a organisée juste pas
pourquoi quand on ne sait pas répondre à
une question on ne dit pas je ne sais
pas donc on fait semblant de savoir
pourquoi des années on a confondu bas
parce qu on a confondu la science et la
recherche
relation cdc un corpus de connaissances
qu'on a du mal à remettre en cause sauf
si on est sauf si on a des arguments
scientifiques pour le faire comme la
terre est ronde ça résultats
scientifiques l'atome existe six
invitations vous pouvez contester mais
il faut des arguments très solides que
personne ne connaît à ce jour pour le
faire donc la science c'est un corpus de
connaissances qu'on peut pas
rejeter l'un janin
facilement dix ans je le sens pas où ça
me parle pas
par contre cette science elles
constituent un corpus de connaissances
qui par nature est pas con struction
incomplet et donc ils posent des
questions dont nous n'avons pas les
réponses et c'est pour cela qu'on fait
de la recherche et quand on confond les
deux la science et la recherche le doute
qui est le moteur de la recherche vient
colonisés l'idée même de sciences et on
dit la science et le doute et comme on
voit des experts qui sont pas d'accord
entre eux on se sent d'autant plus
encouragés à dire ce qu'on pense avec
son ressenti son bon sens ses croyances
des questions qui font controverse pour
les experts il ya même peut-être une
ambiance générale qui laisserait
entendre qu'on ne supporte pas l'idée
qu'il puisse y avoir des sachants comme
s'il y avait une sorte de jusqu'au
boutisme de l'égalité du savoir et de la
parole toutes nos paroles se valaient ce
qu'on avait pas besoin oui c'est à dire
que dans les mêmes qu'à d'autres
circulent et de communication circulent
des connaissances des croyances des
commentaires les opinions des faits qui
nous lient les statuts de ces choses qui
sont très différentes se mélangent du
coup et si moi je parle en tant que ça
change on pourra accuser en fait de
distiller la croyance de la communauté
call j'appartiens et si on présente une
croyance et bien on pourra m'expliquer
quel est en fait une connaissance qui
est injustement les priver des draps et
si on essayait grand défi dangereux pour
la recherche des dangereux pour les
scientifiques que vous êtes ça freine la
recherche oui moi je pense qu'il ya des
leçons à tirer le colis par exemple
quand un scientifique parle en période
de crise dans un lieu public il devrait
plutôt dire nous savons que nous devrons
engager une collectivité la science ne
se fait pas tout seul
quand on se pose une question on fait
des recherches et on présente ses
résultats est la seule à se connecter
qu'on doit avoir c'est de présenter
quelques claques on a obtenu à d'autres
personnes qui s'intéressent à des
questions semblables et travailler sur
des sujets voisins donc il ya un manque
d'humilité de la part positive et dire
je quand on est chercheur ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens c'est le sauve six ans
les lanceurs d'alert auquel cas on peut
parler en son nom propre mais sinon il
ya un philosophe des sciences que j'aime
beaucoup karl popper qui disait la
science c'est la coopération amicalement
au style des citoyens de la communauté
du savoir donc les chercheurs c'est des
gens qui te tant qu'ils n'ont pas la
réponse de la question qui se pose se
disputent et à la fin tout se passe bien
ils prétendent avoir fait parler un bout
du réel ça s'appelle une connaissance et
cette connaissance ils sont tous
capables de la dire de la même façon en
disant nous savons que ça c'est la
science et nous nous demandons si ça
c'est la recherche parlons un peu de
vous de votre parcours vous avez un
esprit scientifique dès le début vous
c'était un peu familial de se diriger
vers la science je crois que votre père
était ingénieur en électrotechnique il y
avait une forme de continuité c'était
logique j'aimais beaucoup les
mathématiques j'aimais beaucoup la
poésie
la littérature
et qui m'a fait bifurquer en fait c'est
à l'âge de 20 ans j'étais dans une école
d'ingénieurs un stage d'été que j'ai
fait au laboratoire de physique des
particules européen le cern à genève il
a j'ai découvert un monde
dont j'avais jamais entendu parler et
j'ai été saisi alors il y avait le goût
d'apprendre chez vous et je crois votre
force de travail aussi j'ai lu que vous
étiez un travailleur acharné depuis
l'enfance et même vous qui demandez à
votre père de changer d'établissement
parce qu à orsay les élèves déclencher
des alarmes
des alertes à la bombe pour éviter de
faire des évaluations c'est vrai c'est
vrai mais je sais pas comment vous
l'avez su se fait des recherches merci
je cherche c'est vrai oui moi je voulais
métiers différents et des fréquences
vous étiez surdoué moi je savais
sentiment que les études constituer une
forme de salut voilà
que je voulais
accédez à des connaissances qui me
ferait regarder le monde différemment
et ça a marché mais est ce que ça fait
de vous un enfant différent je pensais
ça parce que j'ai lu que vous aviez
aussi pris une gifle qui vous avait
crevé le tampon oui et qui est fait que
vous aviez été opéré à plusieurs
reprises du tympan et que c'est même à
ce moment là vous découvrez la physique
quantique parce qu'un élève un camarade
vous allez vite à la ligue 1 qui a eu
pour moi une puissance destine halles
qui s'appelle à la recherche du réel
écrit par un physicien théoricien et qui
s'appelait bernard d'espagnat ce livre
m'a montré qu' il ya des résultats de
physique qui correspondent à ce qu'on
appelle des découvertes philosophique
négative car la physique ne vient pas
remplacer la philosophie mais autour
d'une question philosophique par exemple
le temps existe-t-il elle vient apporter
des résultats qui viennent contraindre
éclairer l'ensemble des réponses
philosophique qu'on peut apporter une
question philosophique et ça voudrait
dire que en certains endroits il ya des
points de contact entre la physique ces
résultats et la philosophie
et ça ça m'a passionné et ça d'ailleurs
quelques temps plus tard j'ai pu
rencontrer bernard d'espagnat qui a été
mon maître et qui avec lequel j'ai écrit
un livre et ça a été à la fois la
lecture du livre est l'événement qu'a
concile la rencontre avec lui deux
moments absolument cruciaux dans mon
évolution une évolution c'est pas
continue mais des moments de bifurcation
est-ce qu'on peut développer avec vous
cette question du temps sur laquelle
vous revenez assez régulièrement c'est
une question qui m'a obsédé en fait
pendant plus de dix ans en fait j'ai
parti d'un vraiment d'une question
triviale j'ai remarqué comme comme vous
que les philosophes parle du temps
depuis que la philosophie
aristote saint-augustin quand husserl
heidegger merleau ponty personnes
mais les physiciens parle du temps aussi
aller galilée newton einstein et
beaucoup d'autres et donc la question
basique que cela pose est celle-ci quand
un philosophe talent du temps est-ce
qu'ils parlent de la même chose qu'un
physicien
oui ou non
si la réponse est non pourquoi c'est le
même mot
on devrait légèrement différent selon
qu'il s'agit du temps des physiciens ou
du temps des philosophes et puis s'ils
parlent de la même chose est-ce qu'ils
ont disent les mêmes choses à l'évidence
non einstein ne parle pas comme
saint-augustin ni comme heidegger donc
qui devait vous l'écoutez si la question
du temps qui vous intéressent j'ai un
document pour vous etienne klein
documents à vous proposer qui nous a été
transmis par les archives nationales
n'allez peut-être pas à comprendre tout
de suite de quoi il s'agit assez peu
lisible mais sont des bulletins de notes
c'est un récapitulatif des trois années
de formation de boris vian à l'école
centrale oui boris vian le parolier le
chanteur critique musical poète et
écrivain et est ingénieur diplômé de
centrale comme vous lui sa spécialité
c'était la métallurgie lui était
scientifiques et artistes et vous vous
êtes physicien et philosophe les
sciences mène à tout etienne klein on
n'empêche rien mais on peut pas vivre je
peux dire on peut pas exister simplement
avec la science
on se dit on à des passions la des
activités on peut faire du sport et donc
on ne peut pas se laisser enfermer dans
la science ne suffit pas par contre
c'est un un lieu d'ouverture pour toutes
sortes de choses bonjour et qu'il était
bonne élève il était très bon et bien
sûr certains documents des archives
nationales sont nos partenaires ah bah
voilà ça vous le saviez vous saviez
qu'il avait fait sens très bien sûr bien
sûr il est très connu dans les collines
et même une référence même s'il a été
caché je crois pendant quelques années
mais c'est devenu une référence une
fierté presque et il savait qu'il avait
une maladie cardiaque qui le condamnait
savait qu'il allait mourir jeune ça
c'est très important pourquoi de
toujours penser qu'on peut moins jeunes
à se permettre ça oblige la ne pas
procrastiner pas perdre de temps plus
tard on en revient celle à faire ce
qu'on doit faire et je pense que c'est
une leçon qui vaut pour tous même si on
a un très bon coeur vous vivez comme
cela aussi en vous disant que vous
pouvez mourir demain oui moi j'ai des
envies de chanter pas aussi grave mais
pendant un certain temps j'ai cru que et
sa hache et ça ça fait qu'on ait fait je
je ne progresse ninja mais c'est quoi
l'idée de mort pour un physicien canton
pour officier la matière de risque et
des matières y mord dans la matière se
transforme elle ne tombe jamais dans le
néant
autour de la conservation donc la mort
est pas quelque chose que les physiciens
peut vraiment décrire ils peuvent
décrire des transitions des
métamorphoses n'est pas la mort au sens
d'une chute dans néant
même les biologistes 1 je crois ils
peuvent décrire le vieillissement mais
l'abandon total en tant qu'événement
elle est incommensurable avec tous les
éléments qui peuvent servir dans la vie
par définition
donc la mort elle reste un mystère et je
crois pas qu'on puisse un jour
fonder ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
chance de la mort on peut comprendre ce
qui se passe biologiquement au moment où
ça se passe d'abord est-ce que ça se
passe on un instant où est ce que c'est
un processus qui occupe une certaine
durée mais après même même les gens qui
racontent des des expériences près de la
mort comme on dit c'est qu'ils ont des
comas pictures viennent ce qu'ils nous
disent est un enseignement à propos de
certains état de conscience modifiée
mais pas de la mort qui sont revenus en
la mort c'est par définition ce dont
nous on ne revient pas et donc on n'a
aucun témoignage sur profil de cette
archive et de ce parcours de boris vian
était à la fois un artiste et un
scientifique est ce que dira qu'il y à
des esprits scientifiques et des esprits
littéraire ce qu on dit beaucoup dans le
langage courant est ce que c'est une
légende selon pure légende et je pense
qu'elle fait des drames dans la façon
dont on peut ressentir une bonne nation
par exemple on croit que plus on est
scientifique - et littéraire au
questionnaire pur littéraire on pourra
pas faire de mathématiques mais ça vient
de
structuration des esprits qui serait
l'effet intellectuelle d'un des
marquages cérébrale qui serait que
certains seraient rose serait plus apte
à ceci ou à cela également assez
populaire m les cases aime les
catégories ben
moi non c'est pas que j'aime pas les
frontières j'ai rien contre les fournir
mais je les vois pas je ne les voit pas
on me l'a reproché mais c'est pas du
tout la transgression est con comme
prochainement massif du mont blanc avant
qui est des téléphones portables on sait
je ne savais jamais si on est en france
en italie
en suisse
quelle importance et on en parlera du
mont blanc dans une seconde est ce que
vous êtes vous arrivé à la philosophie
faute de pouvoir aussi peut-être trouver
des réponses suffisantes dans la science
c'est plutôt que je me rendais compte
que
la science ne s'épuise pas elle même ses
terres qu'elles posent des questions
auxquelles elle ne répond pas et que
c'est donc une ouverture pour un certain
type de philosophie par exemple rien ils
utilisent des les lois physiques il ya
des lois physiques on apprend à l'école
et d'autres qu'on apprend plus tard mais
ces lois physiques quel est leur statut
est ce qu'elles sont dans le monde à ce
qu'elles sont immanente à ce qu'elles
étaient là avant le big bang à ce que
l'univers s'il est apparu est né avec un
arsenal législatif qui ça parce qu'on
est au sénat et déjà fixé à l'as vence
où est ce que les lois se structurent ce
ce apparaissent à mesure que l'univers
les réclament personne n'en sait rien et
donc le fait que la science répond à des
questions mais ne répond pas à toutes
les questions qu'elle oblige à poser ça
ouvre des perspectives fascinantes qui
moi mon ont fasciné ap en fait ça vous a
ouvert voilà philosophie parfois ça
ouvre à la religion aussi est-ce que
c'est compatible d'être scientifique et
croyais en moi je réponds simple je
connais des vivien je connais des
catholiques je connais des physiciens
public mais je ne connais pas de
physique atomique
et je ne connais pas d'exemple de
personnes qui aient changé leur attitude
vis-à-vis de dieu paris l'ombre à cause
de résultats scientifiques est-ce que
les philosophies vous êtes d'où vous a
aidé à poser des limites à la recherche
scientifique est ce qu il doit y en
avoir d'ailleurs des limites à la
recherche scientifique je pensais à
science sans conscience n'est que ruine
de l'âme alors dans l'est parce que on a
longtemps cru au progrès on n'emploie
plus le mot mais le monde le prend la
science a été le moteur de la science
mais aujourd'hui on y croit moins et du
coup on se rend compte que la science
elle produit des connaissances mais elle
produit aussi de la certitude menace
cette étude d'un type très spécial c'est
que la science ne nous dit pas ce que
nous devons faire des possibilités
qu'elle nous donne par exemple d'essence
vous permet de faire des ogm des mythes
des des opérations génétique de
différentes natures est ce qu'on doit
les faire ou pas las on ne dit pas elle
nous dit comment le faire mais ne dit
pas si on doit le faire et c'est pour ça
que dans une société comme la nôtre
démocratique on doit pouvoir décider du
type de compagnonnage que nous voulons
faire collectivement avec les nouvelles
technologies cela suppose des débats qui
sont très difficile d'organiser parce
que j'observe moi une forme de de
décorrélation sur ces questions là entre
la militance et la compétence je veux
dire par là que les jonctions très
militants pourront contre anti aux pros
sont pas sont pas toujours les plus
compétents et le fait d'être militant
d'abord une opinion tranchée des douanes
de l'envi de s'instruire à propos de ce
sur quoi on a une opinion tranchée moi
j'ai des amis qui sont pros 5g à fond
j'en redemande qu'est ce que la singer
l'apra trop dit c'est pas trop dire j'ai
visionné qui sont très anti 5g genre
demande c'est quoi la singer ça pas trop
dire autrement dit les nouvelles
technologies sont beaucoup plus jugée à
partir de leur halo symbolique qu'à
partir d'une connaissance matériel et
objective de ce qu'elles sont réellement
et ça ça rend les débats
sur les fait ressembler à des débats de
on met en compétition des valeurs
beaucoup plus que des qualités vous vous
situez où vous là dedans justement est
ce que il faut faire attention à ce
progrès scientifique et ce qu'il faut y
mettre des limites ce que l'innovation
scientifique pourrait un jour tu es la
matière vivante toute matière il faut
moi je pense qu'il faut surveiller
l'évolution des technologies comme le
lait sur le feu
alors qu'avant quand on croyait aux
progrès de la science permettent de
faire ceci allons-y allons-y foncé ou
ont fait pas d'omelette sans casser les
hommes et la marche vers le progrès
réclament des sacrifices mais donc cette
remise en question d'innovation
scientifique c'est un peu nouveau il un
discours un peu oui mais encore une fois
elle doit s'appuyer sur des
connaissances autrement dit la militance
doit conduire à une augmentation de nos
connaissances si je m'intéresse au
nucléaire
je dois me forger une opinion et se
forger une opinion ce n'est pas la même
chose que avoir une opinion c'est
demande un travail tellement de discuter
de s'instruire d'interpeller les experts
et ouvre à l'issue d'un processus qui
peut être long je peux dire que je me
suis forgé une opinion et donc ça ça
montre que soul et le le droit de savoir
que tout le monde revendique qui est
parfaitement légitime ray mais pas
toujours aisément converti en désir de
connaître
le plaisir de connaître il est
chronophage
le nucléaire c'est compliqué la somme
j'ai c'est compliqué les ogm c'est
compliqué l'intelligence artificielle
c'est compliqué et pourtant c'est une
question fondamentale pour nos sociétés
l'intelligence artificielle
c'est déjà le cas change plus la vie des
gens que beaucoup de lois qui sont
votées au parlement je le dis sans
ironie et vous dites c'est long ça
suppose même on s'intéresse de très près
que voulons nous faire belle quels sont
les pouvoirs que nous sommes prêts à lui
déléguer et quels sont les pouvoirs dont
nous voulons nous sommes humains garder
la complète maîtrise est ce qui est des
sujets que vous n'avez encore jamais
exploré que vous auriez aimé explorer il
n'avait pas fait parce que j'ai lu votre
parcours vous avez prêtre 50
publications à votre actif celui de 2021
c'est l'esprit du corps mais je peux en
citer plein d'autres le goût du vrai ce
qui est sans être tout à fait est ce que
il ya encore un domaine dans lequel vous
n'avez pas
que vous n'avez pas exploré que vous
auriez m'explose alors - le grand
domaine c'était le temps le vide
l'espace la matière c'est déjà pas mal
donc faux nez c'est des mots et des maux
dont par les physiciens mais aussi l'on
parle le philosophe et qui sont des mots
de la langue courante et donc c'est
intéressant de voir qu'est ce qu'on peut
vraiment dire sachant qu'ils ont déjà
été traités de mille manières mais
l'action qui m'intéresse moi sa
maintenance et c'est les idées
qu'elle sait quoi une idée et commence à
germes j'ai aussi des photos pour vous
des photos à vous montrer
je vais commencer par celle ci c'est une
photo de la prison de fresnes dans le
val-de-marne
je sais que ça vous parle et on va faire
comprendre un autre public pourquoi ça
vous parle je crois savoir là aussi en
ayant fait des recherches que vous y
avez donné des cours les jeudis
après-midi ou peut-être vous voulez
donner encore d'ailleurs le milieu
carcéral vous fasciner vous avez dit un
jour qui vous aspire est psychiquement
par un étrange effet de répulsion
négative
bon vous êtes très informés
et formés
mais non je crois quand j'ai donné des
cours à la prison de fresnes et en effet
il ya une espèce d'aspiration j'étais
attiré par ce milieu précisément parce
que je ne comprenais pas comment on
pouvait y vivre
une sorte de recherche de l'impossible
et j'y ai joué des relations très fortes
en y donnant des cours vous y est vous
avez compris que
c'était pas des cours plaitis vous avez
une réponse à votre question des profils
extrêmement différent et
j'ai toujours été intéressé par cette
question aujourd'hui je donne plus de
cours à la prison de fresnes mais j'ai
donne des conférences dans d'autres
prisons s'est interrompue pendant que
vides et puis j'ai rencontré il ya pas
très longtemps françois bès
qui est un monsieur qu'on a longtemps
surnommé le roi d'évasion s'il ya 17
fois de prison ils étaient 26 ans de
prison total et il a découvert spinoza
en prison c'est devenu un spécialiste de
spinoza et c'est un homme que j'ai
rencontré plusieurs reprises et qui
c'est qui qui les choses qui résonne
enfin qui résonne en moi
donc on peut vivre en prison sa
condition de quoi faire de la
philosophie de ces 26 chez lui me dit
qu'il n'a jamais été en prison il est
passé 26 ans mais il a toujours eu
l'esprit ailleurs sans jamais délire et
donc ça dit des choses aussi sur le
travail mental qu'on peut faire dans de
telles situations j'ai une deuxième
photo qui normalement devrait vous
parlez aussi si mes recherches sont
bonnes si jonny wilkinson ancien joueur
de rugby international
star en angleterre un fan de physique
quantique latérite riche département
culture d'une école d'ingénieur avait lu
cette interview de wilkinson dans
laquelle il disait qu'il avait été sauvé
de la dépression par la physique
quantique et puis dans le même temps
albert fert prix nobel de physique
disait que jeune il avait joué au rugby
dans une équipe de france international
de l'étudiant je crois et donc son idée
avait été de faire discuter jonny
wilkison rugbyman intéressé par la
physique avec un physicien versés par le
rugby mais albert fert tout dernier
moment n'a pas pu venir et dont je je
les remplace est accompagné de jean
iliopoulos un physicien théoricien
et
au moment de partir pour rejoindre le
lieu où avait lieu la discussion elle
m'appelle pour me dire que tu connais où
il en est catastrophé parce qu'il a
oublié ses boutons de manchette donc
elle me demande de venir avec une paire
de boutons de manchette ce que je fais
j'ai pas trop l'habitude mais je les
accroche
à ma chemise est arrivé là bas je me
rends compte que j'en ai perdu 1 on
présente avec tout ça je suis désolé car
boutons de manchette il m'a fait cette
réplique incroyable elle m'a dit ça
n'est pas grave je vais me couper un
bras
on a discuté pendant deux heures c'était
passionnant c'est un petit livre qu'il
appelle le rugby quantique en fait ce
qui l'intéressait c'était pas la
physique quantique elle même mais plutôt
ce qu'on pourrait appeler le new age il
accompagne parfois
une dernière photo et vous l'avez un
tout petit peu dit tout à l'heure alors
ça veut dire quelque chose aux gens qui
nous écoutent c'est une photo du mont
blanc et pour cause vers l'âge de 20 ans
vous vous lancez dans le tour du
mont-blanc et là c'est le choc c'est la
révélation qu'elle est cette relation à
la montagne oui moi j'ai une vie faite
de choc c'était le déclic je ne sais pas
la haute montagne et à 20 ans je la
découvre la première fois et
j'ai j'étais petit compris tout métier
démonte oppose qu'on est adhérent autre
taupe hausses d'impôts c'est le lieu où
je me sens bien j'ai beaucoup d'amis où
je vais à chaque fois qu'une vacance se
présente c'est quoi cette relation la
montagne c'est quoi cette relation vide
à la hauteur à l'immensité bachelard à
une belle expression il parle parler de
la philosophie de nietzsche en fait s'il
applique à la montagne il parlait depuis
schisme ascensionnel d'accord c'est bien
quand vous êtes en bas
vous ne pouvez pas faire autrement que
regarder en haut il nous reste un tout
petit peu de temps et c'est notre
dernière question c'est notre rituel
dans cette émission nous sommes dans un
lieu magnifique et nous sommes avec des
statuts qui représentent chacune une
vertu il ya derrière vous la sagesse il
ay ay si la prudence ici la justice est
derrière moi l'éloquence à laquelle de
ses vertus vous vous reconnaissez le
plus
elle sera de faire des mélanges mais
bien sûr moi je m'entraîne la justice
l'éloquence ensemble pourquoi la justice
et la justice au sens commun du terme
mais c'est aussi penser juste ce qui est
pas la même chose que la sagesse
nous semble que la sagesse elle invite
parfois à borner la pensée or la
philosophie c'est aussi une part de
folie je pense je mettrai la justice au
sens large du terme on sait juste et
l'éloquence parce que toute la question
finalement se fait du langage
comment il ya une sorte
d'incommensurables it et entre la pensée
de langage tout langage et une trahison
de la pensée et l'éloquence et ce qui
permet de réduire cet écart au maximum
et j'espère qu'on n'aura pas trop très
vite votre pensée vous ne l'aurez pas
vous-même trail avec vos mots merci
infiniment merci d'avoir été notre
invité dans un monde un regard on se
retrouve très vite sur public sénat
[Musique]